the Roman Empire expands with  unrelenting force today race celebrate  the power of road they ruled with  intimidation fear and death welcome home  brother please I need you to tell me who  once enemies Oksana and with name names  stamp out revolt in every corner of the  Empire  Rosella no we've done nothing wrong  runs calling for blood crucified God has  a plan for you  no matter where you're from your God is  the glory of Rome brace for impact  how long were you was leave that is what  is your name better my family was  betrayed by my own brother I won't let  him go unpunished what he's done to us  if your brother was the pride of Rome  they beat him and you'll defeat an  empire you should have killed me I will  people would follow you I would follow  you  Oh Alan find out brother  I get what you've done  first to finish  allow us to die